and the big guy shawn monae on the mound
as we indicated he started the playoff
game the
wildfire game against the rays last
october after making just five starts
during the regular season he was 4-0
exceptional 1.21 earned run average in
those starts to short
a little weird action on it marcus picks
it up and throws and they still got him
that ball man but hit right off the end
of the bat
but it's a three-up three-down inning
for sean manaya
dylan bundy acquired this past off
season for the baltimore orioles
fastball 1994 slider curveball split
change
bundy's next delivery and that is a
swing and a miss off speed
full simeon and struck him out went away
so here's trout
so we're looking forward to getting him
back trout called out on strikes
well sean manaya has been absolutely
filling
up the strike zone and no difference
here against mike trout you're just
enough but i think you're ready to go
and if it's in the strike zone you got
to try to do some damage here
that is hammered out toward left field
robbie grossman going back he pulls up
that one is off the top of the wall and
gone
big fly for justin upton and the angels
have a one-nothing lead
good to see that from jay up going yard
here
in oakland first hit
first run of the game 299th
career home run one-nothing halo's
bottom of the fourth and the pitch
and that is a called third strike an
off-speed delivery
perfectly placed slider we talked about
that slider with dylan bundy and that is
when he's able to spot it on that
outside part of the plate and then a
little bit later in the game we'll be
able to push that
just off that outside part of the plate
and start getting some swings and misses
at it
here's the payoff delivery and he got
him fishing at that one
slider struck him out and the inning is
over
so here is simmons batting now and he
has a chance to do something pair on
runners at first and second two outs one
nothing angels in the fifth
ward at second base dossie at first
one-two pitch handleton rips one out
toward left field that will go into the
corner and go for extra bases
ward scores max dossier's gonna be
stopped at third angelton simmons in a
second with an rbi double two-nothing
angels
well that's the consistent symbol with
runners in scoring position
turn on that one off speed pitch inner
half of the plate
and he turns on it just above the belt
nice job as far as bringing his hands in
and lines it in the corner
for a double his first rbi of the season
fletch really good in these
scenarios last year runners in scoring
position in two hours
that has driven out toward left field
robbie grossman going back still can't
get it
over his head one hops defense two runs
in david fletcher with his first
extra base [ __ ] a couple of rbis makes
it four-nothing angels
fletch those hands so quick
back-to-back doubles double-double
just above the belt as well and fletch
flick grossman was going to cut in
between going all the way back to the
wall
trout over two with the ground out and a
strikeout
tough play right field and biscotti
[Applause]
and there's one that's waved and missed
and biscotti looked bad
chasing that pitch struck him out one
away
here's the next pitch that is uh called
third strike throw down the second is
late that's going to be a stolen base
oh this this is a good slider right down
the heart of the plate and we talked
about bundy is
not quick to home plate
here comes robbie grossman he's looking
for a little two-out rally here
middleton with the 2-2 hit hard toward
left the base hit city lands in front of
hermeso
here comes biscotti around third and he
will score the a's first run of the day
robbie grossman and opposite fia line
drive
single gets oakland on the board and
they trail 4-1
so here's alan their young catcher in
nine hole hitter batting with
two outs and two on they actually have
the tying run at the plate right now
two outs here you need and out he's
trying to get back in this game and the
next pitch that's grounded sharply but
right to second handled there by la
stella he'll throw out allen
and the inning ends on a 4-3 ground out
and he is
simeon at second loriano's at first all
of a sudden
the tying run is coming up that chapman
that is out toward the shortstop barrier
that gets the out at second they turn to
double play
nice yeah nice turn they you take that
over strikeout any day of the week that
is a huge double play turn
how about stellen a nice job as far as
turning double plays
first two games of the season
the bobble quickly got rid of it tommy
ostella stayed in there well again
loriano's went out of hard twice
back-to-back days
on the hard slide not enough to stop
tommy boy from turning two
off speed bouncer back to the bow nice
job by ty to be able to finish it off
after two hits in a row
territory leaps up makes the catch light
that baby up as the angels
pick up their first win of the season
this afternoon in oakland
4-1 the final